future man Center organ produces future
man yes do you hang out with Seth a lot
on the set of future men on the set yeah
he's uh he yeah he was great he was you
know he's heavily involved in the whole
thing he directed the first three
episodes we hung out a little bit on set
I mean it was like the end of the day
one day and I was going to like I had a
question for him in the trailer and I
went to knock knock go ahead open the
trailer that door just got like
instantly passed out I think it was it
was an indica strain oh I thought it was
his breath no are you that nice for the
guy no it's just you know everyone you
work with you notice hot theme to
everyone you work with every single
person yeah I don't know what is I track
them I don't know I don't know yeah
who's your next movie with Snoop Dogg
what's gonna happen they said me you
were gonna talk about that yeah must be
a secret yeah yeah yeah so but Sethi
says you have a lovely guy he's great
he's amazing he's yeah he's super funny
super down-to-earth and just like I
don't know he's a normal dude he happens
to be like absolutely hilarious and you
know lives in the clouds but you know
what he doesn't feel like he's impaired
in any way he's one of those peanuts
almost like an argument for smoking
marijuana he'd better
he's a very good writer producer actor
and it doesn't it doesn't feel like his
pot smoking is the way in any fad in any
fashion that's not a good message to be
saying on television all I'm sober 30 he
only seems to become more successful
right we got the more pot he's smart
no I do not condone we do not condone
that in Seth yeah he's one of a kind yes
he's one of a kind it's only Seth only
people shouldn't get near that yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah all right so tell us
about future man
yeah future man is a crazy action-comedy
time-travel show where my character is a
janitor also plays video games beats
this video game and ends up having to go
on a journey to save all of mankind came
up with that oh yeah I'm gonna say Seth
came up with this idea yeah exactly the
point exactly the mind only getting
sharper by the tope yeah so he plays a
video game he defeats the video game
yeah and then a character is how he
becomes the chosen one yes and he's just
very he's very ill fitted to become an
actual hero and you find that out very
quickly throughout the show but yeah
it's it's a crazy show the places I did
things on this show that I never thought
I'd do let alone like immortalized in
front of the camera for all to see
you